andrew is with us in North Carolina hi
Andrew how are you hey Dave thanks for
having me
certainly how can I help so I just came
across this video as a couple days ago
and I kind of bought in almost
immediately it's a finance has been an
issue in my family you know for the you
know several years
I just living paycheck to paycheck and
feeling like we're the only four for all
the time so I'm in and uh only hang-up
is I got to get going to my wife I tell
her about it and I tell summer plans I
hate this like this what we need to do
and she's all fighting the well with it
except we have a vehicle issue to that
final girl in our family and we have one
small compact vehicle and one SUV that's
questionable at best it has its days
where it doesn't start up and the last
thing she wants to do is be stranded on
this outer road with a vehicle that
doesn't start and so in the last thing I
want to do is take out another loan one
time to do the debt snowball so I want
to get your opinion on what what we
should do how many kids have you got I
got one daughter but we're gonna what
looking to expand in the next year or
two okay so you got you're gonna get
some time got a little bit at a time
yeah yeah but I don't know how long did
she help us kinda see the SUV has yeah
but the small car will carry one kid
smaller carries one kid yes yeah so till
you got two kids you don't have a
problem right the problem is is that
based on what I've you know I've
calculated out tries to calculate the
schedule of payments for all our debt
and it doesn't put our debt being paid
off for another four to five years and
so so that kind of puts us that's where
the hang-up is you know what kind of
debt have you got got about sixty
on what my wife student loans of the
other car and credit cards
what do you owe on the car cars about
6000 and the credit cards about five and
even the new ones about 50 what's your
household income I bring my gross income
is 90
I work for this for a city so it takes
out the pension program so there's it's
a little less than that and what your
wife does not work outside the home
correct you to stay at home mother okay
all right what's her degree in mine hers
she's got a marketing degree great she
needs a side hustle that she does from
home I agree I think I think she would
agree to hear this is uh you know
probably there she could probably mess
around helping some people on a
consulting basis and bring in fifteen
twenty thirty thousand bucks do you I I
don't know I didn't know where to start
with that I mean do you have any
suggestions or has she actually worked
in the marketing field or she just got
her degree in it she just got her degree
got a couple years ago okay but she's
never had a job in that field correct
okay all right
don't know exactly where to start off
the top of my head but the good news is
she's got some knowledge that is
valuable and and it might be she plugs
in with some existing marketing firms
and does some remote part-time work for
them okay so start finding some
marketing firms in your immediate area
what part of North Carolina are you in
Charlotte oh good it's a great market
okay yeah there'll be some marketing
firms in that area that they could
probably use just her market her Bay
smart marketing knowledge and it's
literally something she does well the
baby's asleep
I'm not suggesting she not be a mommy if
she wants to be a mommy I'm with her
okay but the good news is that she's got
a marketable thing that'll help here
okay
that's thing number one that comes to
mind thing number two that comes to mind
is this Andrew it never works out
exactly like you think it's going to
when you first find this stuff it's
either worse or better and I think it's
better than you think it is sixty
thousand dollars is not four years
thirty thousand dollars a year for two
years pays it off you make ninety great
well we also just recently purchased a
house that's probably a little more than
you recommend as well so what's your
house payment
nineteen hundred yeah okay so now we
know why you have a car problem right
yeah okay she's gonna have to earn some
income you may have to have earn some
income and you guys need to be on beans
and rice rice and beans and not be
traveling and not be going out to eat
and all this other stuff you need to get
this mess cleaned up and when you got to
start doing all of that I think you can
be out of debt in two years and I think
that's going to be before baby comes and
I think you'll be able to save up and
buy a little better car for cash it
won't be a car you keep around a long
time but it'll be better than the
broken-down SUV you've got today and you
limp through until then but I think
you're done in two years you're going to
have a really wild two years but I think
you can make it so what I want you to do
is I want you and your wife to go
through Financial Peace University it's
our nine week class and a one-year
membership to a full suite of things
including community that you get plugged
into every dollar our budgeting app plus
which connects to your bank and helps
you to update and run everything and the
whole bit so hold on I'll have Kelly
pick up we're gonna get you guys signed
up for that you're brand new to
everything I think this is going to be
harder than you thought it was but I
think it's gonna happen faster than you
thought it was which solves the car
problem you don't have to make a car
decision today there's no reason to all
you need to work on the days getting out
of debt and then if and
when a baby is on the way we will stop
talking talk about stopping and saving
up and buying a little better car but I
don't think I think you're gonna be out
of debt for it all happens I really do
depends on what she makes on her side
gig but she needs one starting today
ready set go
hang on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get
you guys signed up for that